EXTREME WITH TACTICS OF, QUOTE,
UNIMAGINABLE BRUTALITY.
ITS BRUTALITY SO EXTREME THAT
FOR YOU TO TRULY UNDERSTAND IT
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SHOW SOME OF
IT.
AND WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO SHOW IS
CERTAINLY NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
CHILDREN.
THIS REPORT FROM CNN'S NIC
ROBERTSON WILL RUN ABOUT THREE
MINUTES LONG.
WE WILL DISCUSS NIC'S REPORTING
BUT WE WON'T SHOW ANY MORE OF
THE GRAPHIC IMAGES.
ISIS HAS BUILT A MILITARY
STRATEGY THAT RELIES ON A
DETAILED CATALOGING OF TERROR TO
INSTALL FEAR.
A STRATEGY THAT RAISES QUESTIONS
ABOUT THOSE WHO FOLLOW THAT
STRATEGY.
>> Reporter: THE MORE ISIS
GROWS, THE MORE IT FIGHTS LIKE A
REGULAR ARMY.
INFANTRY BACKED UP BY ARTILLERY.
TACTICS THAT HAVE LANDED THEM
HEAVY WEAPONS.
BUT DON'T BE FOOLED.
THESE FIGHTERS ARE BARBARIC IN A
WAY NO FIGHTING FORCE HAS EVER
BEEN BEFORE.
CATALOGING AND POSTING IN NEAR
REAL-TIME THEIR WAR CRIMES.
LAST WEEK, PICTURES EMERGED FROM
HUMAN RIGHTS GROUPS SHOWING MORE
THAN 100 CAPTURED SYRIAN
SOLDIERS, PARADED IN THEIR
UNDERWEAR.
THEN IMAGES OF THOSE SAME MEN
DEAD.
BUT ISIS WANTED TO MAKE SURE THE
WORLD KNEW IT WAS RESPONSIBLE,
WASTING LITTLE TIME POSTING THIS
VIDEO.
[ GUNFIRE ]
SHOWING COMMANDERS GIVING THE
ORDER TO FIRE.
THEN THE NAUSEATING HAIL OF
BULLETS.
CONFIRMATION OF HOW THOSE
SOLDIERS WERE BRUTALLY EXECUTED.
ITS PROPAGANDA.
LIKE ME, YOU WANT TO TURN AWAY.
BUT WHEN WE DO, WE GIVE IN.
WE ARE TEAR EARIZED.
AND THEIR GOAL IS ACHIEVED.
ALMOST A DECADE AGO, AL QAEDA IN
IRAQ, WHICH ULTIMATELY MORPHED
INTO ISIS, WAS LED BY THIS
VIOLENT JIHADIST.
HE SPRUNG TO FAME, BEHEADING
AMERICAN BUSINESSMAN NICHOLAS
BERG.
BIN LADEN'S DEPUTY, AYMAN AL
ZAWAHIRI, WROTE HIM, CRITICIZING
HIS BLOOD-THIRSTY TACTICS.
THE BEHEADINGS STOPPED.
BUT WHEN ISIS MURDERED JAMES
FOLEY IN THE SAME WAY, THE SAME
AL QAEDA CO-LEADER HAS NO
RESPONSE.
AT LEAST NOT YET.
AS A RESULT, EXTREME VIOLENCE
FOR PROPAGANDA SEEMS TO HAVE NO
BOUNDS.
ISIS' WHOLESALE SLAUGHTER IS
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN THE
ORGANIZATION NOW.
EVEN WOMEN.
EVEN YOUNG CHILDREN.
ARE GIVEN SEVERED HEADS TO HOLD.
ISIS LEADER BAGHDADI IS MARRIAGE
ANALYZING AL QAEDA'S CORE.
WHICH MEANS WHEN HIS PROTEGEES
TARGET THE WEST, IT COULD BE
EVEN MORE DESPICABLE THAN THE
TERROR WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST.
THESE ARE FIGHTERS WHO HAVE SO
DEBASED AND DEGRADED THEMSELVES
THEY HAVE LOST MORAL COMPASS.
AS ANY REGULAR MILITARY
COMMANDER WILL TELL YOU, THAT
PUTS THEM ALMOST BEYOND CONTROL
AND ULTIMATELY A DANGER TO THEIR
OWN ORGANIZATION.
BUT UNLESS THEY IMPLODE, DESPITE
THE VENEER OF A REGULAR ARMY,
THEY'LL LIKELY BE MORE HORRORS
LIKE THESE.
>> NIC JOINS US LIVE.
I WANT TO SEIZE ON ONE OF THE
LAST THINGS THAT YOU JUST SAID
IN THAT REMARKABLE REPORT.
THAT IS THIS, THEY HAVE SO
DEBASED AND DEGRADED THEMSELVES
THAT ULTIMATELY THEY COULD BE A
DANGER TO THEIR OWN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S WHAT MANY IN THE WEST
WOULD THINK.
AND YET THERE IS THIS
JUGGERNAUT.
THESE KINDS OF HORRORS SEEM TO
APPEAL TO THOSE THEY'RE TRYING
TO RECRUIT.
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY QUALIFY THESE
TWO OPPOSING THEORIES?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY, THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD ASPIRE TO
BEING ABLE TO ATTACK THE WEST IN
ANY WAY POSSIBLE.
BUT ANY SOLDIER WILL TELL YOU
THIS, UNTIL YOU'VE BEEN IN
COMBAT, UNTIL YOU'VE SEEN HOW
BAD IT IS, UNTIL YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED IT, YOU CANNOT
COMPREHEND THE EFFECT IT HAS ON
YOU.
THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN SUCH BRUTAL KILLINGS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO WALK
AWAY MENTALLY UNSCATHED.
THEY'RE GETTING ENGAGED IN WHAT
WE WOULD REGARD AS INHUMAN ACTS.
THEY ARE INHUMAN ACTS.
BUT THESE ARE ONLY HUMANS.
AND IT IS GOING TO DAMAGE THEM.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT HERE ARE THE
AMPUTATIONS THEY'RE DOING, THE
CRUCIFIXIONS THEY'RE DOING.
THIS TAKES THEM DOWN A MENTAL
PATH THAT TAKES -- THAT WITHOUT
HELP YOU